>> Yes I believe it is very important. One
of the problems that the Middle East is suffering
from is how many young people do we have,
and the amount of despair and lack of role
models that exist. I think the role models
play a key role in setting the stage and agenda
for a world that can hopefully be more peaceful
hopefully and more ethical. I think people
are looking at today's leaders and we are
brutally disappointed or feel lost. There
is no clarity of an election, for them to
inspire to be like. And more importantly corruption
seems to be the name of a lot of games being
played whether it's in politics or across
the world or just in the Middle East. We feel
that there are a lot of other reasons and
motivations behind what is being done. I think
we all need role models, but particularly
younger generations. And when you look at
the percentage of young people in the Middle
East over all you can see 60-70 percent are
below the age of 25. They need to see the
way to make it to the top, the way to succeed.
They still have a clear vision, good education,
good ethics, hard working, and really have
a view for a better future for everybody not
just in good of interest or other countries
in the world. Thank you.